how to chop an onion this is the root
that's absolutely crucial leave that on
there if you cut that off the onion will
start to bleed and you'll start crying
rapidly slice go forward that way to the
knife do the work three fingers one in
front two behind and this part of the
knuckle is gonna guide the knife fingers
on top of the onion to point the knife
towards the root and try to get as close
to the root as possible nice long stroke
and then push the onion back together
push the knife halfway in to the onion
slightly tilt the knife down one at the
top and then gripping the onion like a
tennis ball holding it together in place
with the weight of the blade to cut
through that onion to get to the base of
the root again turn it around up and
down motion and that's what we left
there no waste just the root and look
there you've got a really nice finely
chopped onion seasoned and cover well
with paprika spread evenly useful Pierce
that open squeeze it in that delicious